[Music]
former President Obama didn't just
attempt to remake his own past but also
the success America enjoyed in the
aftermath of the Cold War
watch the Washington Consensus whatever
you want to call it got a little too
comfortable with you know they're
looking to GDP numbers and they're
looking at you know the internet and
everything is looking pretty great and
particularly after the Cold War Jimbo
you know after what you guys engineer
you have this period yeah of great
smugness on the part of America and
American elites thinking we got this all
figured out joining me now Reagan
historian and author of rendezvous a
destiny Craig Shirley Craig you were
particularly struck by a former
President Obama's historical illiteracy
please explain well Laura I can't
understand why he wouldn't be smug about
the winning of the Cold War and we've
got won the Cold War we didn't end the
Cold War but we freed millions of people
formerly in prison behind the Iron
Curtain we tore down an evil empire
which literally Ronald Reagan literally
change the world in previous presidents
is that we should have been smug I think
one of the great failings when the wall
finally fell and Gorbachev resigned of
the George HW Bush administration is he
never went on national television to
explain to the American people why the
anti-communist policies of Harry Truman
Dwight Eisenhower John Kennedy and every
president going forward and why the
policies of 55,000 boys didn't die in
vain in Vietnam why the vigil are long
Twilight Struggle against Soviet
Communism wasn't a great struggle yes
one of the great yes exactly and it we
should have been smug we won the good
guys won and the bad guys lost we should
have been smug no you're smug today when
you pass Obamacare and then the website
doesn't look really schmuck about Craig
I got to play something I do I got I got
to play something else too because we
don't uh no time identity politics was
discussed at length last night and
need for civility like we had civility
during Obama or in the recent past and
now we have no civility apparently
because of Fox News talk radio and a few
conservative websites but this is what
he said about identity politics and
where it all began let's watch when I
hear people say they don't like identity
politics they don't like I think it's
important to remember that identity
politics doesn't just apply when it's
like people or gay people are women no
you know the folks who really originated
identity politics when folks who said
you know three-fifths clause and all
that stuff yeah that was identity
politics Jim Crow was identity politics
that's where it started thoughts there
yeah well he's just lost all those
teleprompter isn't he is that I he
talked about Jim Crow in the context of
the American Revolution is that Jim Crow
was a hundred years later and without
the framework of that was created the
brilliance of the framers in
Philadelphia in 1787 he never would have
been elected president we never would
have had the chance to pass the 13th and
14th amendments to the Constitution so
is that to attack the framers and
founders as being admired and identity
politics we were the American Revolution
was about escaping him the identity
politics of the British Empire worse
British subjects had rights and American
subjects had no rights I can't think of
any better example of identity politics
than that well so he went to pretty good
schools right Craig I mean he's
incredibly well educated and well did he
crack a book well I mean they you know
everyone complains they say I'm saying
all the things they complain about Trump
well though he doesn't read enough
history he doesn't all the things the
elites come over he's narcissistic he's
thin-skinned he's obsessed with his own
yeah I mean what person who runs for
president except for Reagan maybe isn't
doesn't have an outsized ego they all do
but for all the things they criticize
Trump for watching Obama last night he's
kind of a cool cat he has really cool
approach but come on he's so mad about
Trump's success
he's so enraged that things have gone
really well on the economy so he has to
say I did it I find that
it's just not that mature for someone
who fancies himself this mature kind of
elite well-educated individual yeah he
said something curious too he said well
nobody was indicted of course you just
went through a whole litany of the
scandals that were attended to the Obama
in two years eight years in office you
one thing you overlooked was the the
criminal use of the IRS to shut down the
hundreds of but he said but he said
nobody was indicted is that that's like
saying well I should go on Mount
Rushmore because I didn't rob banks I
mean that's not really you know
something to really boast about is to
say well nobody was indicted has the
Nobel Committee ever been the same since
President Obama won the Nobel Prize I
mean that's no we it was amazing yeah
yeah but but you go back to the Japan
occupation by Douglas MacArthur he
deserved a Nobel Prize for that and he
never got it alright Craig thanks so
much